some super interesting primary results
from yesterday progressive activist
corey bush has defeated
10 term u.s congressman lacey clay
in the democratic primary in the first
district in missouri
and this is an interesting seat because
it has actually been
in the clay family since the 1960s bill
clay represented the district for 30
years
then his son william lacy clay
jr was elected in
so it's been since the 1960s that this
seat
has been in the same family in missouri
now back in 2018 corey bush ran against
lacy clay
and lost by 20 points not a small
defeat there for cory bush last night
she won roughly 51 to 49 percent
as of the latest numbers i saw corey
bush
is a nurse and an activist and this is a
pretty similar situation to aoc's
district
in new york city where the winner of the
democratic primary
is overwhelmingly likely to win the
general in november so essentially
the democratic primary is is really the
big election there is a republican
candidate it's anthony rogers he won the
republican primary
uh last night as well and it is you
might be
if you're not familiar with the missouri
first district you might be surprised to
hear that it is such a safe district for
for democrats
uh it's an extremely uh urban district
so as we know
in the united states there are voting
differences among
uh religions there are voting
differences among age voting differences
among race but the urban rural divide is
also
significant and this is a very urban
district and widely expected
to go to cory bush in a similar
situation as that which we saw
with aoc not long ago now
there's an important reminder here about
how you we can't really evaluate the
potential impact of a biden presidency
without taking into consideration the
house and senate now we've talked about
the senate before and with the senate
it's a much more obvious analysis which
is
if republicans can continue to control
the senate
during joe biden's at least first two
years in office if biden were to win
there's going to be a dramatically
smaller number
of even potential big progressive
victories if you have biden in the oval
office
a democratically controlled house and a
republican senate
it's going to be a fight it's going to
be obstruction and the amount that can
get done is going to be
much more limited if democrats can take
the senate
and keep the house and joe biden wins
you will have a two-year period during
which you could see
some pretty major progressive
advancements made they might not be
perfect they might
not be what bernie would do but they
would be significant and notable
advancements
in the progressive in the potentially
more progressive house
the effect is more nuanced because what
we're talking about in the house is it's
already democratically controlled every
expectation is that democrats will
retain control in the house of
representatives but
will it move to the left and when corey
bush replaces lacy
lacy clay that is a potential move
to the left for sure and that is a more
nuanced situation
will the bills that make it to biden's
desk
which he will be forced to sign or not
sign
and of course that would be after
conferencing with the senate assuming
democrats take it
a more progressive house also better
positions us
to put more progressive legislation in
front of joe biden
potentially getting him to sign it so
this is a really big deal
and if we do see uh these two years
of total control by democrats white
house
senate house we're very much getting
ahead of ourselves we're not going to
put the cart before the horse here
you could see one of the greatest
reversals in a two-year period
from the completely whacked and
outrageous white house of donald trump
with a republican senate that has gotten
so many judges
in appointed in confirmed for life
positions
you could actually see a really big
reversal uh to american politics
would it be what bernie would do if he
was given carte blanche no but that's
not the system we have we have a system
where we have a house
we have a senate uh we we have states
rights
we have a white house and it would be a
very very interesting situation now as
far as corey bush
she supports medicare for all she
supports a green new deal
supports 15 minimum wage wants public
funding of elections and takes no
corporate pac money so a very
interesting replacement to the uh uh
cur still incumbent as far as the house
is concerned
uh lacy clay this also this is
maybe one other angle worth touching on
this does suggest that aoc was not an
anomaly or an anomaly
both of course valid pronunciations and
that this may be a real wave
of replacing some of these more
entrenched legacy democrats
with younger more progressive
alternatives
the effect that they will have much like
in 2010 when the tea party
surfaced and won a bunch of seats
just because they were winning seats
didn't tell us what effect they would
have on the national politics or on the
republican party
we later saw that they certainly uh
became a notable voice in the republican
party and was sort of absorbed into it
now there's a tea party caucus
still an open question what the longer
term effect is
uh of these progressive victories in the
house and much of it will depend again
on the circumstances of who's in the
white house starting in january
and who controls the senate starting in
january and whether you do or don't like
any individual policy from any of these
progressive replacements to legacy
democrats that's
less important than the realization that
there is a changing of the guard
happening here
the i don't think that can be denied
anymore the open question that we will
have to answer over time
is what will the effect be on not just
the ideology of the country
but on the policy of the country as well